[Musique]
bonjour bonjour maltais vous m'avez dit
qu'aujourd'hui on va aller faire la fête
oui alors que cette eau pour un repas de
fête dans votre rion des landes et b
chez moi en feu repas de fête on se met
à table et on y reste bien bambara pour
être incapable longtemps ont fait
plusieurs plats bon et aujourd'hui on va
nous faire des crépines est au foie gras
et on va faire une dinde aux cayes
pour commencer pour commencer alors que
faut-il essentiellement pour faire des
crédits nets et d'inde
aucun il faut de très bonnes choses mais
à la portée d'un peu de tout le monde
alors il faut tout d'abord bon jambon
bien de chez nous il nous faut un bon
malgré deux canaux le canard bien
entendu il nous faut notre marbella
ventrèche j'adore il me faut de
l'armagnac
il nous faut une belle bande il nous
faut de jolis cailloux
il nous faut bien entendu des bruits des
truffes sur la chance d'avoir tous les
français avaient des origines de truffes
il nous faut du foie gras pour la dinde
et pour les cahiers il nous faut des
réserves alors quand on a la chance
d'avoir des réserves très bon en
fédérale 1 fry et autres marc hé bien on
se contente des raisins qui rend peu
dans l'armagnac
il nous faut des foies de volaille il
nous faut de la crépinette de porte
il nous faut heures jolis morceaux de
veau et puis on travaille
et avec ça on va faire le plat de
résistance est à craindre est ce que
c'est copieux et bien méritée on va
commencer par les crépinettes au foie
gras alors qu'allez vous mettre dedans
on va mettre du jambon de la ventrèche
de l'échalote alors vous allez commencer
le hachey on a déjà mis un peu de jambes
ans que nous avons treize membres de la
france vous vous régalerez chaleur
quelques échalotes
on va remettre un petit peu de jambon
là c'est donc à les y voilà
moi je vais préparer ma crépinette je
vais brutale et je fais de la place puis
voilà
vous pouvez être là alors la voilà et là
dessus je lui mettre un peu de raison
qu'on ne savait pas parce que le jambon
est salée oui je le mets large
là je mets une petite couche de farce
oui je me pose de mon assiette ici oui
je les coupe comme dans ma foie gras je
vais le couper de traction deux
escalopes il faut ce qu'il faut et c'est
la fête c'est jean marc était en fait un
bon repas où on a fait pareil maintenant
je vais y mettre du magret oui oui où on
peut mettre pareil le mari de susan
aucune importance et oui au choix au
petit bonheur la chance
mais en gardant un peu du gras du magret
il le faut parce que ça fout de toute
façon sa forme et il faudra surveiller
la cuisson vous allez voir on va
remettre même trois ans mais la wii la
regardez les bien joli mais on remet une
autre couche de farce parce un peu de
truffaut nan nan en eau par d'or alors
je vais sortir
merci mifid les intrus avant sur le
magret et oui pour donner du goût à
l'intérieur voilà les paradeurs n'est ni
très bien d'après en remet une autre
couche de farce oui voila je parce
qu'elle est assez grande parce que on
peut faire ça et chez les partenaires
épaisseur mais là je crois que pour nous
ça suffit pas ce qu'on va la faire cuire
à la cheminée on pourra la toile on a
repris la voie là et ce n'est que
l'entrée comme vous nous avez dit alors
ça sera une empreinte très raisonnable
et ça ça se plie bien vous prenez la
crépinette vous la coupe est comme ça
tout le tour oui et puis or vous tournez
là elle voilà la crépinette et qui est
prête à accueillir
on va la pire dans la cheminée sur la
braise bien ce qu'on a la chance d'avoir
cette belle cheminée en associant savoir
faire
oui ils vous compter à peu près combien
de temps mais il faut une vo ça dépend
des vrais de conan est là une bonne demi
heure c'est sûr voilà tranquille une
bonne devenir oui ça va nous laisser le
temps de nous occuper de la dame c'est
celui des cayes produits être bien sûr
alors que fait et bien on va forcir
notre alors que met-on en partie à eh
bien on met du jambon de l'échalote
on a commencé une fois cent fois oui on
lâche tout ça on a mis le veau pour en
finir de le mettre un art vous vous
lavez revenir comme un livre ouvert
oui on fait revenir le veau tout seul
parce que le veau est plus lent à cuire
mais après il faudra refaire votre cuir
tout dire que vous n'aurez rien que dans
la d'un nom mais il requiert le farsi
jouer de la stran voilà et ensuite vous
allez tout de suite le passé adrian
joliment gas et moi je vous passez de la
chine très bien voilà je crois que ça
doit les abats parce qu'il faut parler
plus longtemps il faut transformer un
peu parce que j'aborde l'oignon laden
est très épaisse alors si on y va tous
surtout cru dedans et vous savez on va
ressortir qui avait pas tellement
puisque c'est non et non là ça va être
puis on va y mettre un petit peu de
poivre pas du sel puisque le sel c'est
le jambon il s'en occupe
oui la jambe ont ils à battre le psg a
retiré sa licence et oui la renvoie
l'affairé et vous d'y ajouter quelque
chose vous arrosez avec quelque chose
mais après après on va le mettre là bas
parce qu'il faut pas que sa cuisine
on va bien sûr nos compétiteurs bagnac
c'est la vie ça va de soi
beaucoup de charme à y ajouter sa finale
armagnac à m ona le foie gras avait
aussi remanié una les truffes et les
brisures de truffe et qui ne voient pas
gâcher voilà je vous donne l'armagnac
d'en bas record pour laisser cuire et
quand même il faut que l'accusé me
dupeux et pendant que la criminelle
contenu à cuire on la retourne et elle
est bien dorée belle
qu'est ce que vous faites là gros film
de l'armagnac dans c'est fini on les
perd maintenant on prend lavagnac après
vous me passez les truffes
là un petit soupçon d'armagnac vous le
redonne sa tombe et les brisures de
truffe
oui c'est vraiment repas de noël
c'est le cas de ça il faut ce qu'il faut
comme les grands le foie gras vous donne
un morceau ici tout simplement oui ça
c'est la première qualité lancé le reste
du foie gras tout à l'heure oui on a
gaspillé alors là grossièrement on
couple ça grossièrement c'est pas la
peine de s'impliquer parce qu'ils font
plus ou moins vous retomberez les
morceaux quand même bien oui les jolis
morceaux et on va aller remplir notre
d'inde qui nous attend gentiment là bas
là que vous faire un peu de place
oui voilà il voulait rien pliciers par
valérie oui normalement en train de
pousser voulant repousser l'heure on a
un peu la remplir par le cou pour
qu'elle garde le jus un petit peu plus
oui mais c'est pas facile il faut avoir
énormément l'otan oui parce que le coût
est tout petit dannik là et bien là
c'est encore au mieux je vais prendre
opérer sa voix là et on remplit où il a
levé un petit peu d'envolées ouvrait la
bouche d'un petit peu là et vous savez
ça va être bon mais il faut surtout pas
oublier de faire cuire leur farce
un peu avant et oui c'est ce que je vois
à complètement 8 mais il faut qu'elle
soit 8 leveaux il a bien cru sa mine
puis cinq minutes d'abord elle reste
aussi à peu près 3 4 minutes bien varié
ça y est et on découvre maintenant on va
prendre un autre fille seule on va faire
un petit tour n'est si vous avez bonne
couture à faire ce qui est la deuxième
[Musique]
c'est cousu main voilà c'est bien fermée
elle est prête maintenant la boule ou
pas tout à fait non non non non non les
fêtes
oui ben laden voilà notre belle d'être
est maintenant et on va la mettre à
cuire mais je me suis blessé
non je lui couper la tête alors à
tourner oui voila je prends mon un choix
juste importés et vous lui coupez le
couple voila voila il y avait bien cousu
là aussi j'ai défendues pour pas que ça
soit parce que je suis ne se lance pas
et bien maintenant je vais m
vela prirent à la broche ah oui parce
que l'on est et qui fait alors pourquoi
ça me gêne mais je n'ai pas craqué les
points mais il faut passer au travers
face aux preuves
ça y est c'est fait est-ce qu'il ne leur
était pas avant de la mettre à la broche
qui ne veulent pas sortir notre devoir
d'être cuit bien sûr bien entendu vous
allez la chercher
voilà oui par les jolies autre jolie la
wii de chez vous en supplions 13 mois
qu'est ce qu'on va voir dedans on va
découvrir
on va découvrir krabi et oui on va
découvrir le foie gras la truffe la
tranches de magret on voit très bien
tous là le magret la prusse
on se brûle aussi affreusement voit on
va la tournée parce que la regarde il
n'y a pas de mal à voir où tout regarder
et maintenabilité faudrait peut-être le
fruit d'un que vous avez ficelé comme un
saucisson qui sera gigoter sur la
branche exactement on va la mettre dans
la cheminée on va la mettre dans la
cheminée
[Musique]
là ça va être plutôt lourd en cuir non
une belle ben oui ça il faut lutter oui
il faut penser une ou deux au à l'aise à
l'aide
voilà 4 août et maintenant les cas les
cages
qu'allons-nous faire avec écailles et
bien on va finir les farcir je vais
mettre leurs réserves
les résines trempé dans l'armagnac je
vais y mettre du foie gras un petit cube
de foie gras un joli morceau et vous
tasser avec le doigt et ça passe après
je vais finir de remplir avec la farce
quand je me suis servi pour la belle
tout à l'heure c'est la même famille et
ont du coup le derrière
voilà c'est terminé c'est pas compliqué
voilà on avait quelques unes qu'on avait
préparé à la vraie ans donc on va
pouvoir mettre tout cuir à la fois en
cuir à la fois pendant ce temps notre
dame je crois qu'elle retirait bien
j'attends des bruits sympathie si ça va
dans notre dos à dos les frais bien
voilà on va les mettre la cheminée on a
préparé des petites ficelles
je vais vous les donner oui voilà si
vous donnez beaucoup à la fois mais je
voulais tient-il de la voilà voilà
là on va mettre ça est d'or ça fait très
joli et de deux ça va bien cuire voilà
et de trous noirs qui devrait se régaler
la bière démocratique c'est joli c'est
beau quand on a tout ce qu'il faut et
quand même
et voilà et les autres et puis et puis
on va préparer les croûtons et d'autres
bombes pen est en panne et kate est
fabriqué en hollande et la nostra qui
qualifie ce qui vire et maggy khoudja
amour qu'est-ce que vous refera et donc
a écrit tourner la comédie pour vivre
brebis qui ont le vertige
ouf et oui il est vrai d'ailleurs alors
même que les couples et un occupé dans
le mettre dans quoi dans la grèce dans
la graisse de canard sont pas les
bienvenus dans les landes on va les
dorés des deux côtés oui le héros a
présenté les cailles les cailles bien
attendez quand elles seront qu'une part
les nefs bière la jolie parce que ça
c'est du pm sensationnel pour sa
sensationnelle
il y aurait des deux côtés et dort et
des deux premiers clients
voilà et on a le temps puisque les cayes
dans la cheminée leur faut à peu près
combien de temps ont une bonne heure et
demie très bien
la dalle est cuite est bien dorée maïté
lie alors elles sont trop jolie avec
leur bec en l'air c'est aujourd'hui le
plat est terminée pas tout à fait la
dernière opération la plus part des plus
importantes villes de plus importante
oui on va le chercher notre concurrent
qui a chauffé à blanc dans la cheminée
vous allez lui m le lard n'a essayé
voilà et ça ça se termine
et cela arrange énormément on va rose et
d'autres petites écailles en même temps
un point la good ça va deux jambes ont
reculé pour terminer bien voilà voilà
les crépinettes que vous avez vu tout à
l'heure la dinde farcie les cailles
c'est un vrai repas de noël pour vous
maïté c'est un début de repas de noël
d'un début et bien voilà la suite on ne
pourra peut-être imaginer plus tard pour
aujourd'hui bon courage pour en faire
autant au revoir et à bientôt
et ceux pouvant bon appétit
le